I got some cakes for us the prepares for
this episode
I got a delightful strawberry okay whoa
yeah look at that
yeah I'm talking about ow mmm today
we're going pie today that worth it
we're gonna try three pies at three
dresses two different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
at its price which one do you like
better
pirate cake and why create your three
paragraph as I eat miss a bit to my
Dropbox
okay here's why I like pie better I like
pie better because it is usually less
sweet and I like pie better because
there is more contrast and texture
available period end of paragraph my
turn food is about sharing experiences
and what food is better at sharing
experiences than cake I'm just saying
more of the time I'm more down to have
five I want to enter the bait without
having to get all of an army okay all I
want to do is share some pie did it take
on it my name is Michael Osborn I'm the
owner here at lion burger we are gonna
be trying several of our classic fruit
pies today and will feature apple and
boysenberry he tell us a little bit
about the history of pie n burger pie n
burger started in the fall of 1963
the recipes or the same recipes that
started and they actually predated the
restaurant had been here 45 years and we
do things exactly the same way that we
did when we opened with a lot of the
same ingredients so when you join was
your role with the restaurant I was 18
years old and I was a night cook so
really yeah so I was in college at the
University of Southern California I
started working here with the idea that
I would be here a couple years to make a
little money and then I was gonna go on
and be a dentist Oh people to the
dentist yeah yes exactly how are the
pies made first of all it's all about
ingredients we only use Gold Medal flour
we only use C&H sugar and we never use a
large we use a really high grade
vegetable shortening so we need to go by
hand when we make the dough we like to
let the dough sit for several days and
sort of seize that all of our pies is
almost a full time
centration of fruit there's no fruit
flavors really added to of no machine
you know all hand-done you only have
that one mixer in the back we only use
it to make a few light toppings whipped
cream and things like that we don't use
any of it in our regular pie making
progress whatsoever everything else
about the pie is handmade everything is
hand we measure out each pie we'll put
in the exact amount of fruit every time
and then we'll lay our top crust on the
oven that we use here at pie n burger we
use a pizza deck of it we cook right on
the deck surface and we cook it a little
bit slower temperature it allows the pie
to come in contact directly with the
cooking surface of the oven and it cooks
the bottom of the shell so you don't get
that doughy texture you actually notice
a little bit of brownish on the bottom
of the pie shell itself are you ever
asked about your preference of pie
versus K depends on the day I guess a
little bit I have a preference to pie
over there this pie will be the burger
that's it why I'm writing a story
yes apple pie and pie n burger and a
bowl or pie we're going to shape it
actually looks really good
no no I'm just gonna have anything Oh oh
I'm ready to get into this by a bet oh
look at that clean cut by yours truly
and look how it moves on there's nothing
falling apart I could really do some
gymnastics with this thing there's some
gymnastics oh oh that is real yeah how
Apple is actually taste the thing that
makes pie pie is the end is the
delicious crust yep a lot of times when
there's too much crust it's just dried
out this is still a delicious tender
baked treat just at the end I mean is
there anything more awesome than apple
pie maybe like going your grandma's out
what if she had an apple pie when you've
got there my god that's a movie right
there and the Sikh wall is boysenberry
pie we eat some boys and berries on the
stove to melt them down a little bit to
get consistency we use individually
quick frozen fruit that way we're able
to get voice and berries in the
wintertime when it's not necessarily a
growing season right now we're getting
boys and berries from Chile visually you
have to love a pie with a red filling
this could be a lighthouse Cheers
oh I mean in the fight Wow just the
right amount of thrust
hi dato by taco go ahead fight talk
already
oh yeah I can't understate how perfect
the amount of crust is on this pie oh
okay alright we did not do this wrong
way yep
pyon burger thank you I am literally and
happy oh my god alright these burgers
and we're heading the road going to
Houston
see that bite no Andrew yeah fight back
here's a fight back for you we're in
Houston there's a little desert we got
some sesame balls
mm-hmm Adams having a good time on the
swing set hi back historians believe
that early paedos which mostly consisted
of water and flour and could be quite
thick we're primarily meant to protect
the food inside and weren't always eaten
so pie is used to just be semi edible
boxes for other foods that's right I'm
glad they figured out how to eat it eat
the crust next up we're headed to a
restaurant called underbelly
underbelly under my belly we're just
gonna have some pie but not just some
pie because it is going to bake pie its
cake pie it's a pie with cake in it
that's right we stuck some cake in this
episode bigger pie okay you're off the
show my name is Chris Shepherd a chef
owner near underbelly of Houston today
we were doing the carrot cake fried pie
is that a cake or a pie technically both
but it's a pie fried pie is this a
southern staple around here can you tell
us about what pie is in Houston
proverbial question is cake or pie right
but yes here we're pie so underbelly is
focused on this story of Houston food
it's also the most culturally diverse
city basically the gateway drugs to
people coming into Houston you know
they'll come in and taste something a
bit I really like this flavor but I was
like well this is screen you need to go
up on Long Point now at this point let's
light Victoria kind of show you and walk
you through the fried pie aspect of
things
I'm Victoria Deerman I am the pastry
director I've worked here since
underbelly opened almost six years now
underbelly's entire premise is about
locality so right now it is carrot
season we've got the carrots we shred
them all and make a very traditional
carrot cake then we make the pie crust
unrendered pork fat it's basically the
fat around the kidneys it's much firmer
than the outside fat it's kind of like
protected by meat that's the main part
of the dough's the flour the unrendered
pork fat some salt baking powder and
cold water just get everything in the
mixer I try to let it sit overnight or
at least for a couple hours before I use
it we'll roll them into small bowl and
roll those out so we have our circles
and then we put our okay
and cream cheese icing fold it up pinch
it around the side it's like a little
empanada and then we fry it you always
want them to come out GBD golden-brown
delicious after the pie comes out of the
fryer sprinkle cinnamon and sugar on top
and goes on a plate with candied pecans
and kumquat sour cream ice cream so we
asked the chef where they recommended
drink pairing Victoria gave us this
lovely took what you go
but then chef Chris is going with the
whiskey I love it I love it too Cheers
I don't know how we should do this it's
a hand pie but I'm not gonna hold hands
with you so I'm just gonna take off kind
of like the center chunk Oh seeing the
inside of this makes me go here you have
top crust on both sides so that's like a
win-win pretty good pie yeah
it's ridiculously good kind of like a
Frankenstein dessert experiment but it's
not a monster after all I don't think
there's ever been a real answer to the
pie verses cake debate
the answer is cake pie oh oh there you
go
mmm throw in the ice cream with the pie
and you get like that citrusy flavor
having that zing of that orange a
kumquat it's delightful
what's this oh yeah oh this is the best
part of any ice cream a company dessert
idead will spend 25 minutes going like
this with a bowl of ice cream ice cream
is like the most delicious creamsicle
I've ever had
by Bray Chris Shepherd actually advised
that we while we're here in Houston try
some via Cajun food because the thing
that doin usin according to the American
Pie Council over 180 million pies are
bought at us grocery stores every year
that's enough pies
to circle the globe with leftovers so
now we're going to a place that serves
pumpk apple pie cake that's right we had
cake pie and now we're going hi Kate
[ __ ] apple pie cake come look pepper
boom let's go get some pie cake it is 8
p.m. right now and I am let's get that
pie
[Music]
welcome to three brothers bakery my name
is Robert chucker today we're gonna be
trying the pump like apple pie cake we
got voted by Country Living magazine for
our pecan pie as the best pecan pie and
mail order has to offer one of the
writers for these 2 chronicles Greg
moraga wanted to write an article about
that I started talking to my wife about
having me do something unusual I made
the thumbpick apple pie cake we really
did it as a joke the Food Network found
out about it and then it just really
went viral is it a pie or is it a game
well that's really the question this is
the liger of pie cake more like the
turducken of desserts that's exactly
what it is what are the flavors inside
of this thing apple pie with an apple
spice cake pecan pie with a chocolate
cake and pumpkin pie with a pumpkin
spice okay so there are also three
different kinds of cake yes I first you
got to start with making the pie so we
make the dough for the pie shells
filling in put the latticework on bake
them off then after we get the pies
ready and we cool them off we get the
batter ready for the cake batter and
we pour them in the pan dump the pies
into the pans cover them up with batter
bake them off we let those cool when
they come out of the oven and then we
start to build an apple on the bottom
con in the middle pumpkin on top put the
cream cheese icing in between nuts
around the side and then we drizzle
caramel on top
generally speaking across all desserts
so you more of a pie guy or a cake guy I
took a more of a cake guy really yeah
Wow so you have to understand that I
work here every day right and I'm trying
to lose some way I just like them
without I see yeah it's just the cake
we're going to have three pies in three
cakes in one cake pumpkin pecan apple
pom couple Oh hump the cap um it can
fall Adam was telling me before this
there's a rule to not eat something
that's bigger than the size of your head
too late we're breaking the rule today
that thing bigger my head you got that I
think others this is what they actually
used to cut the pie cake first a bit of
pumpkin then a little bit of apple I'm
gonna hum Canet pumpkin Bowl cheers diva
it's really good when you eat a smoothie
you're important together like bananas
and apples and other flavors together
this is just like the non blended
version of a smoothie funny though
because it started as a joke that's what
true creativity comes out I knew going
in that we were having three pies three
cakes but I forgot about the ice and
components yes so not only is this the
greatest hits of pie flavors but the
greatest frosting yes arguably is the
cream cheese frosting don't worry I did
the pecan pie by itself
wonderful yeah you're never bored eating
this pie cake
there's always another flavor but just
like 3.14 there is no round conclusion
to this pie that's how pie works right
it's been a while Adam would you like to
try the half full of pump buck Apple
pump pick Apple what are you doing
I admit he may have want me over with
this episode pi takes the cake for me
that be at PI which PI was the most
worth to you and it's price for me the
most were that Pi was tying burgers
slice it by the last chapter on a
delicious book called I just made a
burger mine with the winner underbelly
you got both cake and pie in a pie hot
crispy delicious filling and if you went
back there regardless of the filling
that's gonna be a great pie but shout
outs at the pump book apple pie Bobby
figured it out you did it's like landing
on the moon special worth it props to
the pump it got provide Adam who's your
worth a winner oh we're at the hotel yes
it's time to sleep next week coming up
little vampires know we're eating [ __ ]
actually we're doing it right now but
you'll see that next week
teaser alert guys have been asking for
it they've been asking five we're gonna
take a nap get rid of the bad puns
I'll see you next week oh oh yes